Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hato samma-sambuddhassa Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hato samma-sambuddhassa
Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma sambuddhassa Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-enlightened one.
Homage au Bouddha, le noble bienheureux et illuminé.
This evening, I want to see if we can understand the Buddha's psychology
Mais d'abord, une warning.
Le compagnon du Bouddha pendant vingt ans était Ananda.
Et il était cousin du Bouddha.
Il avait une mémoire phénoménale.
Un homme de très grande intelligence.
Et en marchant avec le Bouddha, il dit, vous savez, je pense que je comprends cette dépendance d'origine.
Et une fois qu'il marchait avec lui, il lui dit, tu sais, je crois, je comprends ce que veut dire l'interdépendance.
L'origine.
L'origine interdépendante.
Ah, interdépendante.
Ce qui est la psychologie du Bouddha.
Et le Bouddha a dit, oh non, Ananda,
Cet enseignement est très profond.
Donc en gardant cela à l'esprit, nous allons essayer de comprendre la profondeur de cet enseignement, de l'interdépendance.
Le fondement commence avec le mot avidja, qui signifie ignorance.
Mais cette ignorance n'est pas culpable.
C'est un état de ne pas connaître.
Et c'est à cause de cela qu'un erreur est faite.
C'est à cause de cela qu'il y a une erreur que nous faisons.
Et à partir de cette erreur, nous créons une illusion.
Donc souvent dans les textes Theravada, avidya est traduit par mora ou illusion.
Il y a deux étapes.
Il y a l'étape de ne pas savoir et l'étape de l'illusion.
Confusion.
Si nous prenons ce qui nous arrive quand nous sommes nés, même à l'intérieur de l'utérus, nous commençons à ressentir des sensations comme la voix de notre mère.
et tout à coup nous arrivons au monde et nous sommes là donc nous arrivons au monde avec aucune connaissance de ce qui va se passer, de ce qui va nous arriver
Donc nous devons donner un sens à ce monde.
Et comme vous le savez, de notre propre psychologie, quelque part autour de l'âge de trois ou quatre mois, un objet sort de cette masse de sensations.
Donc, d'après la psychologie, à l'âge de 3-4 mois, il y a un objet qui sort de cette masse de sensations.
Et c'est normalement notre mère.
Et depuis ce point, nous commençons à nous séparer du monde.
A partir de là, nous commençons à nous séparer du monde.
Donc, à un certain moment donné, nous voyons, voilà, ça c'est à l'extérieur et ça c'est moi, c'est à l'intérieur.
Ensuite, nous devons apprendre à créer une relation avec ce monde.
Et la relation que nous allons créer est basée sur une erreur.
L'erreur c'est de croire que le monde va nous donner le bonheur.
Nous développons deux sortes d'attitudes par rapport au monde.
Nous possédons, nous cherchons à acquérir ce que nous pensons qui va nous rendre heureux.
Tout ce qui nous rend malheureux.
Et si ce qui nous rend malheureux est trop grand pour nous, alors à ce moment-là, nous partons au courant.
Et ces deux attitudes d'aversion et de peur, le Bouddha en fait juste une seule parole.
Et donc cette attitude d'aversion et de peur, le Bouddha le nomme avec un seul mot.
Donc dans les textes, vous voyez d'un côté Moha, l'illusion.
Et vous voyez Loba, qui signifie l'acquisitivité, qui se transforme en grève.
De l'autre côté, il y a Loba.
Ce à quoi nous nous accrochons, qui se tourne ensuite en avidité.
De l'autre côté, vous avez Dosa, qui est l'aversion.
Et une fois que nous commençons à agir,
Donc à partir du moment où nous commençons à agir soit à partir de l'acquisition ou de l'aversion, alors toutes les misères du monde nous tombent dessus.
Donc ça c'est le premier produit de cette roue de l'interdépendance, de l'origine interdépendante.
Donc ces créations sont appelées Sankara.
Nous reviendrons à cela dans un petit moment.
donc depuis la naissance et à chaque instant deux facteurs travaillent ensemble donc le premier est l'acte de la cognition et de l'autre côté vous avez le corps et l'esprit
Donc le corps et l'esprit comprennent toutes les sensations, les émotions et les pensées.
On peut dire l'organisme psychophysique.
Mais une partie de cet organisme psychophysique est l'acte de la cognition.
Mais à l'intérieur de ce système, vous avez l'acte de cognition.
Par exemple, vous avez une télévision.
Toutes ces informations viennent sur cet écran.
C'est sur l'écran que l'image va se manifester.
Donc cette manifestation correspond à l'acte de cognition.
Ensuite le Bouddha divise le corps et l'esprit en six sens.
mais aussi l'esprit, ici où l'esprit contacte le cerveau c'est là que l'esprit fait ses premières perceptions
C'est au moment où le cerveau connaît sa première perception.
Donc cela inclut non seulement les perceptions qui viennent des cinq sens, mais aussi ce qui se passe dans le cerveau.
Mais aussi ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de l'esprit lui-même.
Donc malheureusement, nous séparons ce qui vient du cœur et ce qui vient de l'esprit.
Donc d'un côté nous avons le cœur et le monde émotionnel et de l'autre nous avons le mental et toutes les pensées que nous créons.
Mais d'après le bouddhisme tout cela travaille ensemble.
Donc quand je parle de l'esprit, je parle aussi du cœur.
Donc l'acte de cognition met aussi sur l'écran toutes les pensées et les émotions qui apparaissent.
Cela, vous pouvez l'expérimenter pendant la méditation.
Vous pouvez être à l'extérieur de ce processus et voir qu'il y a un acte de cognition.
Le Bouddha utilise le mot Pācchaya qui veut dire dépendant de Donc dépendant de la cognition le corps et la tête apparaissent
Donc, en dépendance à la cognition, le corps et l'esprit vont apparaître, apparaissent.
S'il n'y avait pas de cognition, à ce moment-là, vous ne sauriez pas que vous êtes cet organisme psychophysique.
Donc cet organisme dépend des six sens.
Ceux-là sont ce que nous appelons le donné.
Pour être un être humain, vous avez besoin de ça.
Ou au moins un être humain conscient.
Alors que nous ne pouvons pas dire ce que les gens expérimentent quand ils sont dans ce qui est appelé un état végétal.
Maintenant, parce que nous avons cette cognition, ce corps et les six sens, nous pouvons avoir ce contact.
Et le contact nécessite trois facteurs.
Le contact a besoin de trois facteurs.
Un objet qui peut être ici à l'extérieur ou à l'intérieur comme une pensée.
Vous avez besoin de la base des sens.
Et puis l'acte de cognition.
Par exemple, si je marche dans une pièce sombre, je ne peux rien voir.
Il n'y a pas d'objet.
Si je suis aveugle, je ne vois rien.
Et quand je dors, quand je perds ma conscience ordinaire, je ne vois rien non plus.
Vous pouvez faire cela avec tous les sens.
Donc, à la base du contact, il y a ce que nous pouvons dire la perception simple.
Par exemple, je regarde un objet, je vois la couleur bleue et je vois la forme.
Je peux aussi comprendre que cela est un coussin.
Et donc, il se passe quelque chose, une relation se crée entre à la fois le monde extérieur et le monde à l'intérieur.
une dualité avec le monde.
Tout à coup, nous aimons certaines choses et nous n'aimons pas, nous détestons certaines choses.
Parfois nous aimons très fort quelque chose et puis très fort le contraire.
Et même les sentiments les plus neutres auront une tendance à aller vers j'aime quelque chose ou je n'aime pas.
Ça c'est un donné.
C'est ainsi que nous vivons dans le monde.
Cette dualité ne nous causerait aucun problème.
C'est ainsi que le Bouddha existe.
Il sait ce qui est bien et ce qui n'est pas bien.
Souvenez-vous de votre dernière nourriture.
Souvenez-vous de son dernier repas.
Donc, souvenez-vous de son dernier repas.
Donc, il a offert un morceau de porc.
Donc, ou ce que les porcs mangent.
Ah, c'est bien.
C'est comment je définis le cochon ?
Non.
Ah oui, c'est ça.
On ne sait pas si c'était du porc ou ce que les porcs mangent.
Quand il a mis ça dans la bouche, il a dû sentir quelque chose.
Parce qu'à la fin, ça lui a donné une gastro.
Qui l'a tué.
Et il a dit, avant de mourir, de ne pas blâmer la personne qui lui a donné la nourriture.
Donc il a dit avant de mourir de ne pas blâmer la personne qui lui a donné le repas.
En réalité c'était une bénédiction que ce soit son dernier repas.
Donc cette position de « aimer ou ne pas aimer » est maintenant appelée « Veda ».
Donc cette position de j'aime ou je n'aime pas s'appelle vedana.
Donc ça inclut toutes les sensations, tous les sentiments dans le corps.
Donc les émotions telles qu'elles sont ressenties dans le corps.
Donc tout cela est vedana dans la langue du Bouddha.
Tout cela est inclus sous le terme de Vedana dans le langage bouddhique.
Nous les discernons comme étant plaisantes ou déplaisantes.
C'est là que se manifeste cette erreur originelle.
Rappelez-vous, nous cherchons la bonheur dans le monde.
Donc, souvenez-vous, nous recherchons le bonheur dans le monde.
Et cela veut dire aussi chercher le bonheur dans ce complexe corps-esprit.
Et nous mangeons la nourriture parce qu'elle a bon goût sur la langue.
Autrement, nous ne la mangerons pas.
D'habitude.
et à cause de cette illusion nous formons maintenant une relation active nous voulons ou nous ne voulons pas
Donc là, nous avons cette ligne où toutes les sensations apparaissent, moment après moment.
Et nous jouons le jeu de vouloir cela, de ne pas vouloir cela, etc.
C'est souvent traduit comme « craindre ».
Ces sortes de mots.
À ce point, dans votre méditation, si vous pouvez atteindre ce point-là,
et si pendant la méditation vous pouvez attraper ce moment où vous sentez l'avidité, par exemple pour la nourriture par exemple vous ressentez des émotions qui sont difficiles et vous ressentez cette résistance de ne pas vouloir y aller
Si vous avez trouvé cette position de l'observateur objectif, donc il y a une claire distinction entre celui qui sait et la réaction par rapport au ressenti, demandez-vous-même quand vous êtes dans cette position, suis-je souffrant ?
Posez-vous la question quand vous êtes dans cette position-là, est-ce que je souffre ?
D'après le Bouddha, à ce moment-là, il n'y a en réalité pas de souffrance.
Mais c'est l'étape d'après qui en fait nous noie dans l'insatisfaction.
Et cela s'appelle Upadana ou la saisie.
Et ce qui se passe à ce moment-là, c'est une identification.
Ou une possession.
C'est là que se manifeste le soi.
Au moment où le je rentre en jeu, par rapport à quelque chose qui n'est pas bénéfique, il y a la souffrance.
Il n'y a pas de souffrance jusqu'à ce que le je
Il n'y a pas de souffrance tant que le « je » ne se manifeste pas.
Et à ce point-là, c'est très difficile d'empêcher le moment suivant d'apparaître.
En fait, je dirais que vous ne pouvez pas vraiment l'arrêter.
Mais en réalité, je devrais dire qu'on ne peut pas l'arrêter.
Et parfois, dans la méditation, vous êtes capable de voir comment on est aspiré dans l'objet.
Et ça, c'est l'identification.
Par exemple, vous pourriez avoir expérimenté dans votre vie quotidienne
Vous parlez à quelqu'un et vous ressentez l'irritation.
Et grâce à notre méditation, nous pouvons le ressentir.
Mais nous sommes dans la conversation.
Et avant de le savoir, nous avons perdu cette séparation.
Et avant même que nous nous en apercevions, nous avons perdu cette séparation.
Et voilà, nous sommes en colère.
Et ça sort, vous êtes en colère.
Et même à ce niveau grossier, vous pouvez voir l'identification.
Je devrais plutôt dire que c'est au moment où la colère est sortie que vous pouvez voir là où vous êtes tombé.
Dès l'instant où il y a cette identification ou cette possession, la prochaine étape c'est l'acte de kamma.
Nous faisons quelque chose.
Soit nous le faisons de notre tête à partir des pensées, ou en parole ou en action.
Et à ce moment-là, quelque chose est entré alors que ce n'était qu'au stade du potentiel.
Tant qu'un quelque chose n'est qu'au niveau du souhait et qu'il n'est pas mis en action,
Pour que quelque chose soit mis en action, il y a besoin d'y avoir un renforcement.
Il doit y avoir une énergie pour entrer dans le désir pour qu'il se manifeste.
Et ça c'est la volonté.
Donc c'est pour ça que le Bouddha dit que la volonté c'est l'action, donc la volonté c'est kamma.
Donc c'est la volonté que j'appelle l'action.
Vous ne pouvez pas séparer la volonté de l'action.
Donc, autant que je sache, en science, si vous ne pouvez pas séparer la pierre de son...
Si vous lancez une pierre, vous ne pouvez pas séparer la pierre de la science.
Non, essayons encore, essayons encore, essayons encore.
Même en science.
Donc même en science, une fois que vous avez jeté une pierre, vous ne pouvez pas séparer la force de la pierre.
Et dans l'origine interdépendante, le Bouddha appelle cela « bhava », « de devenir ».
Le Bouddha appelle cela Bava, devenir.
Donc, cet acte de devenir se recrée en permanence.
Non, non.
Donc, le soi se recrée en permanence.
Est-ce
cela c'est l'acte de devenir donc à chaque fois que le soi devient, il renforce ce devenir
Une fois qu'une action a été activée, elle a un début, un milieu et un fin.
Dans cette action de début, milieu et fin, elle a renforcé certains habitudes.
Donc dans cet acte de début, milieu et fin, il y a ce renforcement du devenir.
Donc ça renforce l'habitude.
Donc à chaque fois que je me mets en colère, je renforce cette habitude de me mettre en colère.
et ainsi la roue tourne.
C'est comprendre l'origine interdépendante, moment après moment.
Et pour nous, comme méditateurs, cela fait le plus sens.
Pour nous, les méditants, ça fait beaucoup de sens.
Mais souvent, ça s'étale sur trois vies.
La première étape, c'est l'ignorance, l'illusion, les habitudes que nous avons formées dans une vie précédente.
Et quand nous renaissons à nouveau, ce conditionnement revient dans cette nouvelle vie.
Et selon la vie que nous allons mener, certaines conditions vont être développées et d'autres ne le seront pas.
Et après la mort, le processus de renaissance, de vie et de mort se manifeste à nouveau Tout cela est motivé par une mauvaise compréhension
Donc cette mauvaise compréhension se manifeste à un point de l'origine interdépendante juste cet espace entre le ressenti et la saisie, le désir.
Donc entre vedana.
Ce que nous aimons et n'aimons pas.
Et l'étape suivante qui est de vouloir, ne pas vouloir.
Et c'est là que vous avez la porte de secours.
L'échappe.
L'escape de la souffrance.
C'est pour cela que notre méditation est concernée par la façon dont nous réagissons à quelque chose.
Donc c'est pour cela que dans la méditation, nous sommes concernés pour voir...
Voilà, donc nous sommes concernés de voir comment nous réagissons aux choses.
Donc pendant l'assise, si nous ressentons la douleur dans le genou,
ça c'est vedana désagréable un ressenti désagréable et quand nous résistons, et bien ça c'est le ne pas vouloir
Si nous pouvons laisser passer cette résistance, nous pouvons créer une nouvelle relation avec la douleur.
L'équanimité.
Et quand nous sommes équanimes, il n'y a pas de souffrance.
C'est plus difficile quand il s'agit de choses qui nous plaisent.
C'est plus difficile avec les choses qui nous plaisent.
Parce que quand nous complaisons dans quelque chose, nous sommes heureux.
Mais nous ne voyons pas les conséquences jusqu'à ce que le moment arrive.
Par exemple, quand le cerveau est perdu dans une belle pensée,
Par exemple, lorsque l'esprit est perdu dans une belle pensée.
Donc, vous pouvez voir qu'il y a un désir d'aller là-bas, de créer ce monde.
Si, dans notre méditation, nous ne nous promenons pas à apporter l'attention,
Et si dans la méditation nous ne sommes pas prêts à ramener l'attention, donc nous pouvons tout à coup passer toute une période de méditation perdue dans les rêves.
Donc en quittant le rêve et en revenant au corps, nous pouvons ressentir l'excitation ou la joie.
Et si nous restons suffisamment présents, nous pouvons voir le désir qui veut repartir dans le rêve.
C'est comme un aimant.
Et si vous pouvez rester présents avec cela et attendre que cette énergie se dissipe,
Tout à coup, nous pouvons expérimenter un esprit sans désir.
Et ça, c'est le contentement.
Même ici, nous pouvons avoir un soupçon de l'esprit du Bouddha.
Même dans ces petits moments, nous pouvons commencer à avoir un inclin de ce qu'est vivre dans le monde sans désir.
Donc, à ce moment-là, nous pouvons avoir une petite étincelle de ce que c'est que de vivre dans ce monde avec l'esprit du Bouddha.
Sans désir.
Sans désir, oui, sans désir.
Maintenant,
Ma compréhension a été influencée par les enseignements du Mahayana mais l'enseignant avec lequel je suis le plus en résonance
C'est un maître Thaï qui s'appelle Mahabua.
Vous le connaissez ?
Non ?
Certains d'entre vous l'ont peut-être lu, oui.
Dans la tradition Theravada, vous allez...
Donc dans le bouddhisme Theravada, le nirvana est souvent décrit comme un état d'inconscience.
Mais cela en quelque sorte ne peut pas être vrai puisque le Bouddha était conscient.
Donc il se peut que le Theravada ait décrit ce qui est arrivé au Bouddha après qu'il soit mort.
Donc nous pouvons seulement imaginer ce qui se passe lorsqu'un Bouddha meurt.
Comme nous le savons, dans la tradition Theravada, le Bouddha s'intéresse simplement à la Nibbana totale.
Donc dans la tradition Theravada, le Bouddha, au moment de la mort, entre le nirvana.
Le nirvana complet, total.
Mais dans la tradition Mahayana, le Bouddha peut revenir sur Terre par compassion.
Ou dans d'autres règles, hein ?
ou aussi dans d'autres royaumes, pas seulement sur Terre.
Quand nous commençons à pratiquer Vipassana, nous découvrons ce poste que nous appelons l'observateur.
C'est celui qui sait, connaît.
Donc le mot que je préfère en anglais, c'est l'acte de connaître, de savoir.
C'est le connaissant.
Le connaissant, c'est ça.
En utilisant un mot comme ça,
nous arrête de le transformer en objet mais nous dit ce qu'il fait quand nous méditons, nous étouffons cette roue de l'origination dépendante
Nous la voyons se dérouler.
Et donc ce processus se base à l'intérieur de ce champ de conscience.
Et donc ce connaissant, ce champ de conscience, c'est Satipanya.
Ce qui est l'attention et l'intelligence intuitive.
Il y a une phrase dans les Écritures Theravada.
Je crois que c'est la seule fois qu'elle apparaît.
elle donne une description très positive de ce niveau d'attention et la traduction est comme telle il y a une conscience
qui n'est pas teintée d'aucun sens.
Elle n'est pas teintée d'aucun sens.
Sans limites.
Ce qui signifie qu'il ne peut y avoir aucun phénomène
Les phénomènes créent des limites.
Et dans toutes les directions, remplies de lumière.
Et ça, c'est la réponse à une question.
La question est
Où est-ce que les quatre éléments disparaissent ?
Le Bouddha dit que c'est une mauvaise question.
Mais plutôt, où est-ce que ces quatre éléments ne trouvent pas leurs pieds ?
En d'autres mots, où ne peuvent-ils pas être trouvés ?
En d'autres mots, où est-ce que nous ne pouvons pas les trouver ?
Donc la terre, le feu, le vent et l'eau.
C'est le monde matériel.
Mais ça se réfère au monde matériel comme nous l'expérimentons.
Mais ça fait référence au monde matériel tel que nous l'expérimentons.
Donc c'est la base de toutes nos expériences.
Donc le Bouddha dit qu'il y a une conscience qui n'a rien à voir avec le monde phénoménal.
Et ça c'est l'expérience du nirvana.
Quand nous sommes dans cette position de l'observateur objectif, nous sommes à un seul pas de cette expérience.
Même si c'est une expérience courte, momentanée.
quand vous êtes dans la position de l'observateur, celui qui sait, celui qui ressent il y a la connaissance de quelqu'un qui sent, sait et ressent c'est comme une réflexion
C'est par exemple quand vous regardez la télévision.
Et vous voyez votre reflet dans l'écran.
Donc maintenant, vous pouvez soit regarder la télévision, soit vous-même regarder la télévision.
vous pouvez soit regarder la télé ou voir votre reflet en train de regarder la télévision parfois dans l'assise le sentiment de l'observateur peut être très fort
Et donc j'attends de vous que vous hushiez la tête vigoureusement.
Donc, puisque c'est un objet, cela ne peut pas être vous.
Il ne peut pas être vous, il ne peut pas être le vrai vous, c'est un objet.
Le ressenti d'un self ou le ressenti d'une présence
Donc ce sentiment d'une présence, ça ne peut pas être vous puisque vous êtes en train de vous observer.
Donc si c'est un objet, ça ne peut pas être le sujet.
Maintenant, nous pouvons, par un acte de volonté, nous déplacer dans cette position à l'intérieur de nous-mêmes.
Et par un acte de volonté, nous pouvons nous placer dans ce poste d'observateur.
Parce que ça fait partie du pouvoir du soi.
Mais le soi ne peut pas se débarrasser du soi.
C'est un grand problème.
Donc c'est là que les enseignements du Bouddha sont vraiment les plus subtils.
Donc il dit, continuez d'observer l'objet avec l'intention de voir les trois caractéristiques.
Et à travers notre concentration, le sens du soi disparaît.
Et pendant un moment, il n'y a que le fait de cette connaissance.
Il y a une absorption.
À ce point, nous expérimentons la pure conscience.
Et à ce moment-là, nous faisons l'expérience de la conscience pure.
Donc ces petits moments sont des instants de nirvana.
Mais je ne les appelle pas, ce n'est pas le nirvana.
Ce sont juste des moments d'attention pure où il n'y a pas de souffrance.
et même dans la vie de tous les jours cela peut être une expérience donc quand vous êtes en train de faire quelque chose de bénéfique votre cœur est dans cet état de bonté et en le faisant
Et pendant cette action, vous perdez toute notion de conscience de soi.
Et quand vous redevenez conscient de vous-même, vous pouvez regarder cette action et vous rendre compte que deux choses n'étaient pas présentes.
La conscience de soi,
Et le temps.
Et le temps n'existe pas quand vous êtes demeuré dans cet instant présent.
Oui.
qui n'a pas, je ne sais pas comment dire, qui est toujours présent.
Oui, exactement.
La raison pour laquelle il est toujours présent, c'est parce que cette connaissance n'a aucun début et aucun fin.
Et le fait que cela est toujours présent, c'est que l'attention n'a pas de début et pas de fin.
Il n'a pas de naissance et de mort.
C'est l'inconditionné.
Et cela, le Bouddha le déclare clairement dans son propre vers de victoire.
Donc le Bouddha est très clair dans son vers de victoire, dans lequel il déclare, « J'ai été voyager de vie à vie,
Et donc il témoigne, j'ai parcouru les vies après les autres.
Mais maintenant je t'ai vu au constructeur de maison.
Je t'ai vu au constructeur de maison.
j'ai cassé les toits et les murs j'ai atteint l'esprit inconditionné
et j'ai atteint l'esprit inconditionnel.
Asankhatam chittam, c'est les mots du paulisme.
L'esprit inconditionnel, la conscience inconditionnée.
Nous n'avons pas vraiment une parole pour exprimer cela.
Et toutes mes défaillances ont été complètement détruites.
Tous mes défauts ont été complètement effacés.
Cela est notre destin.
Nous pouvons nous réjouir.
Même si le voyage est difficile,
Même si le chemin est difficile.
Nous devons entreprendre ce chemin.
Et vous qui habitez en Suisse et grimpez sur ces montagnes, vous n'avez pas de problème.
Et cela, nous pouvons l'appeler notre vraie, profonde, existentielle foi.
Et ça, nous pouvons l'appeler cet espoir existentiel profond.
Nous sommes tous destinés à être pleinement éveillés.
Je peux juste espérer que mes mots ont pu vous aider un peu.
Vous puissiez vous libérer mieux tôt que tard.
Merci.